-Hi! I'm SUGA.
Nice to meet you guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Singing,
cheering and applause ]
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Are you okay? Are you okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now BTS is gonna show me
the Idol dance.
Here we go. Ready?
-5, 6, 7, 8!
1, 2, 3, 4,
-Here we go. Ready?
-5, 6, 7, 8!
♪ Oh-oh, ooh-oh, hey ♪
♪ Oh-oh, ooh-oh ♪
-I'm in. I'm in the band.
I'm in the band! Let's go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tell me.
You spoke at the U.N.
You sold out Citi Field
in under 10 minutes.
I mean, this is -- it's a big
deal for you guys.
-It's a big deal.
-What is --
What do you want
to accomplish?
What's next?
What do you want to do?
-[ Speaking native language ]
You know, want to stay humble
and enjoy the ride,
but I think SUGA wants
to say something.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Go.
Let's Go.
-Uh...
-Yeah, Yoon-gi!
-Go to Grammy's.
-Yoon-gi!
-Go to Grammy?
-Go to Grammy.
-Grammy?
-He said Grammy.
Oh, wow. All right.
All right.
We can make that happen.
Dude, we can call them
right now.
Let's make it happen.
-We can just, like, dream, so...
We can dream, so...
-You can dream. Absolutely.
Dude, hashag BTSgrammy
right now.
Let's make this happen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We can dream, so...
-I have questions
from your fans.
"Can you ask BTS,
when they make a song,
what comes first --
the melody or the lyrics?"
-First...
-Beats.
-Yeah.
-The track.
-The beat.
-Track.
-The instrumentals.
-Really?
-Yeah. It always comes first.
-Melody or song --
melody or rap.
-So, first the track.
-Yeah.
-Then, you write the lyrics,
and figure it out?
I think "Dynamite" couldn't have
been a bigger, bigger smash.
I mean, it was massive;
a lot of -- a lot of firsts
for you guys.
First all-English song,
uh, first song to hit number one
on the Billboard Hot 100,
uh, first -- first Korean group
ever to achieve that milestone.
What -- what was your reaction,
like, the night
you found out "Dynamite"
was number one?
-We couldn't believe our eyes,
looking at the chart.
-Yeah!
-It feels like a dream.
-Ooh! Whoa!
-It's amazing.
-Shred it!
-"It's real?! This is real?!"
[ Shuddering ]
-Yo, it's real!
-It's real,
it's definitely real!
Does it make you think about
your own high school experience?
What were you guys like
back then?
SUGA?
-Bad boy.
-Bad!
-No, no.
-That's not good.
-Go!
[ BTS oohs ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-Oh, SUGA!
-Wow! Wow!
[ Rubber duck squeaking ]
♪♪
-Go! Go! Go!
[ Laughter, applause ]
[ Laughing ]
♪♪
[ Bell dinging ]
-SUGA, here we go,
We got nothing to worry about.
Will it fit?
81 candles on a single cupcake.
SUGA says yes!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Tiny cupcake.
Alright, let's go for it.
You ready?
-We don't need the gloves.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Let's go. One.
-Go, go, SUGA.
Go, SUGA.
-Two.
-You have to be very careful.
You have to be very careful.
This is very precise.
-Four.
-I think it's going
to take a while, baby.
-It's going to take
a little while.
-Ohhh!
-♪ Let's go, let's go ♪
-Let's go.
-Yeah. Let's go.
-Yeah. Finish.
-Let's go, let's go.
-Whoa!
There we go.
Look at that. Come on, now.
And a ping pong ball.
Is it true that when you first
started the band,
the seven of you shared
one room?
What was that like?
What did you learn from each
other through that experience?
-"Okay, I hate BTS!"
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah, we are.
What's wrong about it?
[ Laughter ]
Uh, SUGA, is it true that the
first album you bought
was an Eminem CD --
-Oh!
-And what did your parents think
of it?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hey!
...SUGA?
[ Cracks knuckles ]
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
He's a five-time
Grammy-nominated...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...musician, and his music
has been streamed
over 30 billion times.
[ Cheers and applause ]
His new solo album,
"D-DAY," is out now.
Please welcome global pop-music
icon from BTS, SUGA!
[ Cheers and applause ]
How you doing?
Good to see you.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
Thank you for --
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
Thank you for being here.
Uh, Higgins -- Higgins --
Higgins, can you --
Higgins, can you explain how --
[ Cheering continues ]
-Yes, I can, Jimmy!
-Yes.
Explain how the game works.
-Jimmy and SUGA will be given
two things to eat
that look identical.
One tastes good...
and the other does not.
-Okay.
They must eat
what they are presented with
while trying to convince
the audience
that they like the taste.
Then the audience will vote
for who they think
ate the gross thing.
There'll be three rounds.
Okay?
-Three rounds. Okay.
-You ready?
-Yeah, I'm ready.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right.
For the first round,
we have two spoons.
One has salt and one has sugar.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
Jimmy, you will go first.
-Go first.
-You're --
You're my guest.
All right, so one is salt,
one is sugar.
-Jimmy, whenever you're ready.
-All right. And --
-That's your spoon.
♪♪
-Mmmmm!
[ Laughter ]
-SUGA, it's your turn.
Eat whenever you are ready.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
Okay. Audience?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Audience,
time to cast your votes.
[ Laughter ]
You all have your voting
clickers at your seat.
If you think Jimmy
ate the salt...
-I tried.
-...vote Jimmy.
If you think SUGA ate the salt,
vote SUGA.
Ready, guys?
Vote away.
-I think it's pretty obvious
who had the salt,
but maybe some people
aren't convinced.
I tried to act like...
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-Okay.
-Yep.
All right. The votes are in.
Let's see the results.
-Oh, Jimmy.
The audience thinks Jimmy
is the imposter.
Jimmy, let's find out
who actually
ate the salt.
Imposter, reveal yourself.
-He ate the salt.
-I'm the imposter.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Wow.
-You thought he was acting?
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-No, he's just -- He's --
He just took it --
He put his tongue in it
and was like, "Ugh!"
-"I'm not eating that."
-I put a full spoon
of sugar in there.
I go, "Oh, my gosh."
But, wow, I love you guys
for believing me.
All right.
-All right.
-Ready?
Time for round 2.
-Okay.
-The deuce.
Ready?
You're gonna have
two glasses in front of you.
One has vinegar.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
The other has water.
[ Laughter ]
-I know. I don't know.
[ Inhales sharply ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-SUGA, your turn.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right!
Press Jimmy if you think Jimmy
drank the vinegar.
Press SUGA if you think SUGA
Who drank the vinegar?
Ready?
Everybody ready?
Okay, the votes are in.
Let's see the results.
The audience thinks SUGA
is the imposter.
Okay. Let's find out
who drank the vinegar.
Imposter, reveal yourself.
-I drank the vinegar.
Ugh!
That was disgusting.
That was disgusting, dude!
I'm crying. I'm crying.
[ Laughter ]
That was disgusting!
Oh, my gosh.
-Then you're gonna love
this next one.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Next one?
-It's time for the final round.
For this one,
you each have a chicken wing.
One has no spice --
mmm, tasty.
The other has been doused
in Trinidad Scorpion Hot sauce.
[ Laughter, cheers ]
-I never heard of that.
-Well, it's hotter
than a ghost pepper.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
I think you need
a license to touch it.
Okay.
-But he has to --
He has to perform tonight.
-Well...
-He has to sing.
He has to --
Jimmy, whenever you're ready.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-Okay.
-Okay, SUGA. Your turn.
♪♪
[ Cheering ]
Okay.
Gonna count those votes up.
That's scorpion hot pepper.
Votes are in.
Let's see what we got.
They think Jimmy did.
Okay.
Imposter, reveal yourself.
Oh!
Oh, my God.
-No vinegar, no hot.
Well done, audience!
Well done!
Since you did
such a great job guessing,
everyone in the audience
is going home tonight
with a free pint of
Tonight Dough ice cream.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
My thanks with SUGA!
We'll be talking more to SUGA
after the break.
Stick around, everybody!
-Looking good, bud.
Looking good.
Welcome back to the show.
I'm happy you're here.
You have --
the album is finally out.
-Yeah.
-It is out -- "D-DAY."
-"D-DAY."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The documentary is out.
The global tour
just kicked off last week.
How does it all --
[ Cheers and applause ]
How does it all feel?
Yeah.
They love you.
I love you.
Before you were known as SUGA,
I read this somewhere --
tell me if this is true --
you were a food delivery --
delivery guy?
[ Laughter ]
You were very good?
Why?
[ Laughter ]
What made you good?
You just...
[ Laughter ]
That helps.
Yeah, but now
you're who you are.
Congratulations.
I mean, you're -- you're --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm a Knicks fan.
And I saw you yesterday
at the playoffs.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, there you are.
This is...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Looking good.
Exciting news.
You were named
an NBA ambassador.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What -- What does that mean?
What will you be doing
as part of that?
[ Laughter ]
-No!
-No, no.
[ Laughter ]
Did you want to be --
Did you want to be
a professional basketball
player ever?
[ Laughter ]
Are you the best
basketball player in BTS?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Are you kidding me?
-[ Laughing ]
Really?
-I think your name actually --
is it true? --
came from basketball?
Right?
How you got SUGA?
-Yeah.
Shooting guard -- shoo-ga.
-Shooting and guard,
so "shoo-ga."
-"Shoo-ga."
-Yeah.
And then,
can you explain Agust D?
-Yep.
-How? I don't --
-Reverse.
D.T. SUGA.
[ Cheering ]
-Oh.
-Yeah.
My hometown name is Daegu.
-Ah, D.T. SUGA.
-Daegu town SUGA.
Reverse.
Agust D.
-So that's your hometown, D.T.?
-Yeah, D.T.
-D.T. So, D.T. SUGA.
D.T. SUGA is pretty cool, too.
-Mm-hmm.
-But you want to go Agust D?
-No. Drive-through.
D.T.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah, yeah. Drive-through.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I understand, yeah.
Yeah, I understand.
But when -- when you're --
When you're Agust D, are you
different than when you're SUGA?
You are.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You can call me Agust D
or SUGA or Yoongi.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You answer to all that.
-Mm-hmm.
-It's a great record.
Congratulations on this.
What does --
What does "D-DAY" mean to you?
Wow. It's a big deal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And the song you're
performing tonight is "Haegeum."
-Mm-hmm.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not yet.
Soon. Soon.
Not yet, not yet.
Soon, soon, soon.
But you were telling me
that "Haegeum" has two meanings.
-Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
-What are the meanings
of Haegeum?
Do you --
Do you know how to play haegeum?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you sure?
Because...
-Wow.
I stole it
from your dressing room.
No, no.
[ Laughter ]
[ Scraping ]
Give me that, give me that,
give me that.
Yeah, yeah, no.
[ Laughter ]
Let me try.
Quest, can I get a beat?
♪♪
[ Light scraping ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Off-key notes play ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wait!
I got some sound!
-Yeah.
-I got --
-You did.
-You kicked off your
giant world tour last week.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Look at this right here.
This is you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How did it feel
to be back on stage?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The documentary I enjoyed,
it's on Disney+.
It is called
"SUGA: Road to D-DAY."
-Yeah.
-And we get to see
behind the scenes
of how this album
was put together.
Did it bother you having
all the cameras around,
or are you used to it?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's true.
Yeah, you're right. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I do want to show everyone
a clip from the documentary.
Here's a peek at
"SUGA: Road to D-DAY."
Take a look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-SUGA is a musical genius.
When I've listened
to his music on his own,
he's always doing something
I would never expect.
So I always expect the highest
bar from SUGA.
-[ Rapping in Korean ]
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, you were...
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
You're nice enough to be
performing live
to close our show out.
And let me tell you,
it is a performance
like you've never seen.
It is unbelievable.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love it.
There's lasers, there's dancing,
there's everything.
It is so good.
It is like a Grammy performance.
So thank you for being here
and doing that.
It means a lot to us.
Thank you for doing it.
But I was asking you earlier,
do you have any traditions
or any superstitions
or something you do
before every show
even to relax, and you --
Can you tell everyone what
you -- what you told me?
[ Laughter, cheers ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I figured, hey...
-Oh!
-It's not vinegar. That's real.
-It's real.
-It's real. Congratulations.
-Yeah.
-Good luck.
Thank you for being here.
-Yeah.
SUGA, everybody!
Agust D!
[ Cheers and applause ]
When we come back,
SUGA, a.k.a. Agust D,
is performing a song
from his new album, "D-DAY."
Stick around, everybody.
Whoo!